oh oh more more breaking news here on
the five
president trump just tweeting that bill
barr has resigned
tweeting and here i'm quoting deputy
attorney general jeff
rosen an outstanding person will become
acting attorney general highly respected
richard donahue
will be taking over the duties of deputy
attorney general
thank you to all the president went on
to say
just had a very nice meeting with
attorney general bill barr at the white
house
our relationship has been a very good
one
he has done an outstanding job as per
letter bill will be leaving just before
christmas
to spend the holidays with his family
we'll have more for you next on the 5.
oh let me we have the opportunity to
stay i'm sorry
so uh dana what do you make of this as
you heard me say
earlier i think barr was being unfairly
blamed by trump
for not earlier disclosing during the
election
what was going on with hunter biden do
you think that's what's behind this
early resignation well we knew from
i think even about a week ago there was
a article i believe was broken in the
new york times
that said that bill barr was considering
whether to resign
before the end of the administration um
what i would take from the president's
comments just now is that
this was a pretty even if there are hard
feelings perhaps they are not showing
them
in public and that it was an amicable
breakup
and that he has confidence in uh jeffrey
rosen who i used to work with a
wonderful guy
and that bill barr has been a public
servant um
first in the 41 administration now
returning uh for president trump and i
you know
for a long time president trump thought
that bill barr did a great job for him
that i think has changed but again i go
back to
what you just read to me sounds like
president trump uh
taking the high road and taking the
attorney general's letter
at its word and they said they said they
had a good relationship and a good
meeting
i think that that's kind of the way
things should be done
and any sort of rumor mongering about
what their relationship might be i think
will probably
not be the truth because if they met
face to face and had a good meeting
that's the way to do business
uh greg you know it just strikes me jeff
sessions left uh a little early and now
we see bill barr i mean obviously
he could have stayed until the uh
president left office it's just about a
month away so
what do you think is going on well i i
mean
none of this is surprising to me trump's
uh prison the way he looks at
at things he looks at things as
incentives
and disincentives so every time he gets
upset with somebody
he somehow views and this is again this
is just mind reading on my part it may
not i'm completely could be completely
wrong though that's often rare
but he believes that but that he
believes that airing things
publicly can be an incentive
in getting a problem solved or getting a
problem removed
and this i i've seen this happen with
everybody i think that if you get hired
uh by trump um you know that there's an
expiration date
you're not it's it's like it's just the
way it's going to be if you butt heads
because
he's going to say something publicly and
you're going to go and i think that's
just the way it is
um to quote bruce hornsby
all right so greg what about what about
loyalists here because i mean
nobody was more loyal stand by trump
through all the investigations and the
like and now he's gone i think a lot of
people are going to say boy
you know it's just about trump it's
never even about the people who really
took a lot of arrows for him
is that for jesse are you directing that
question at me
to you jesse did yeah jesse yes oh okay
cause
you said greg i know i know we look so
much alike
um although i would never wear such a
ridiculous collar sweater combination
um i i would say this i would say that
when it counted bill barr delivered barr
came in and told mueller and his banded
nitwits
to show your cards they had nothing
after
two years and he shut it down there was
never any collusion
and you can't obstruct a crime you
didn't commit so that was gone
with that said he knew for years even
during impeachment that hunter was up to
no good
that the biden family was up to no good
and he didn't tell anybody about it
now i would have liked to know that
information and i think millions of
americans deserve to know that
information
the only advantage i see to him doing
that
was because it was a covert
investigation they never
alerted hunter to the fact that they
were investigating him
so hunter was running and gunning all
over the world for the last two years
doing god knows what while the feds were
building a case
then when they go from covert to overt
they have it and it's it's pretty
fine-tuned
so that was what i would say would be
the advantage for not
disclosing it to the public
all right so emily quickly there's been
no indictment but barr is gone what do
you make of it
i think the two things that history will
note is number one that it was a
resignation
not a termination and secondly the
respect issue that dana touched on the
fact that the president
very publicly is sending him away yes in
an amicable manner and clearly they're
partying on good terms
those are the things that will be
printed in black and white and i think
looking back
on uh the service of now former or
attorney general barr it's one of
obedience and adherence to doj
guidelines including the fact that they
didn't take visible steps
in the run-up to the election so all of
those are what are important to me to
take away
thanks emily one more